dominique a gagné les deux premiers
matchs j'ai gagné le troisième dominique
est là il est dans son match déjà est ce
que tu es prêt à remettre tout ce que tu
remportes remporté ce soir en jeu
dominique comme enjeu pas pardon thomert
pas dit oui est prêt je suis prêt
opérationnel pour ceux qui n'auraient
pas suivi le déroulé de cette
compétition vous avez un petit peu ma
capitule hâtif et juste après je serai à
la table avec une pression énorme
séparé depuis des décennies il est
imbattable
sont des milliers à avoir voulu
l'affronter sur le plateau de thé pnv
kev adams
patrick bruel
aucun n'a réussi à le battre même pas
novak djokovic
[Musique]
tu vas t'entraîner
mais c'était sans compter sur dominique
son plus grand rival
[Musique]
après deux défaites
une victoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui sera le grand vainqueur du combat
des champions
réponse tout de suite dans tpm tr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dominique je te rappelle que tu as gagné
une playstation 4 un week end et tu
joues au ce soir pour un vélo et une
télé si tu perds tu perds tout si tu
gagnes tu gagnes tout ces bonshommes
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
est-ce que vous êtes prêts oui c'est en
dix points qui est pour moi qui ai pour
dominique arrêter la musique arrêté bond
à ce que tu veux servir jeu d'horreur
c'est pas voilà donc réunis en direct
pour commenter ce match tant attendu du
mur nelson je suis heureuse de vous
avoir à mes côtés pour commenter donc
cette triple moment que je fais ce que
je rappelle que dominique a gagné le
premier match 5 3 ensuite le deuxième
match à 10 à 7
il mène 1-0 maintenant 2 à 0 on peut
dire que cyril hamelin démarre assez
doucement cette rencontre trois jours le
je crois qu'il s'agit du premier à dix
points c'est ça
normalement ces 5 mais ça dépendra donc
voilà c'est déjà de lui la vitesse à
laquelle ça va dit tout ça grâce à terre
battue
pardon c'est réparé dans 3 0 donc pour
dominique je sais pas ce qui se passe
mais cyril est pas 13 ans son téléphone
n'est pas très affûté il ya trois héros
maintenant il faudrait peut-être qu'il
se reprenne un petit peu sinon la
revanche venir risque de durer encore
quelques minutes 5 à 0 5 à 0
jusqu'à 10 effectivement fofana lisez le
pass 1 à 0 en une minute tous les
records sont battus enfin le premier
point compensés par série
c'est vraiment adage la route est encore
longue mais enfin sait-on jamais
l'athlète l'ex et non c'est bon d'être
quelqu'un lui lâcher payet le comté
s'attendent donc voilà rappelons que
dominique a remis en jeu donc tout ce
qu'ils avaient gagné 6 3 c'est quand
même incroyable qu'il est remis en jeu
sont son week-end en amoureux
cette ultime rencontre s'est remis à
jouer série là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est l'homme qu'il faut deux fois les
karoui benjamins région et deux points
d'écart pour emporter en fait le le
match pas à pas la manche c'est cette
manche là franchement là la diabolique
hilaire
c'est sa cape là je sens qu'il ya un
petit peu de sueur froide qui commencent
à arriver sur le flanc de cyril vous
rappelle qu'il a suivi un régime spécial
boulette ou bon set mais les boulettes
qui donnent trop évident que dominique à
quand une petite marche
maintenant il faudrait que series se
reprennent un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
doublage et peur que nous approchions
douche lent de la fin nous sommes à deux
points du match
cette fois que la trottinette électrique
c'est dominique leur passion avec la
faute directe mais faute quand même 8
sage beaucoup de suspense dans cette
rencontre pas beaucoup
d'applaudissements de la part d'un sac
et c'est donc semble-t-il une balle de
match c'est bien ça wigan - quatre
balles de match consécutives
plus que 3 9 6 on constatera quand même
que les points de dominique sont en
train de construire
si j'ose dire alors que les points de
syrie sont souvent sur des fautes
directes mais
[Applaudissements]
ans
toi tu aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
tu t'entraîner 1502 à deux fois deux
heures tout entraîneur je vais contre
novak alors fallait bien que je
m'entraîne non c'est horrible mon chéri
tu gagnes l'apc lopez cap le week-end la
télé et le vélo
[Applaudissements]